on one division i i one of the things
that
i'm so impressed with on this show is
they nail
uh the different and and i don't want to
talk about it in a way that's going to
give anything away but you see the show
evolve and it's mimicking different
genres of television and then you see it
just
open up completely into this whole other
type of show
i've never seen a series quite like it
and it's so well done
um one of the things that i think would
be kind of fun for you
is there's some action in here yeah and
i know just myself
i've always loved anytime in a sketch or
in anything related to comedy when i get
to do
any kind of action it's so much fun
because my inner child comes out
which is actually probably out all the
time but well you got to do a fight
scene
i did i did and that yeah it was it was
thrilling it was thrilling and i rarely
get to do
like choreographed fight scenes in my
career so
so the fact that i had the chance to do
that was so great
and uh um and marvel you know
as far as fight scenes marvel is they're
they're so good
at yeah yeah i mean the the fight
coordinators
they have these great this great team
that helps you you know
choreograph the fight work on you know
making it seem real because they want
everything to seem real
and and we worked with them for weeks
before
we've shot that fight scene like every
day and they train us and
i remember that on the first day of
training uh
the fight coordinator was like so show
us what you know what
how you see the fight scene and i do the
fight scene for them and i remember the
uh
the coordinator being like he's trying
to be nice but he was like
yeah no that that's that's like all
wrong
you know that's not how one fight that's
not how one fight what was the mistake
you were making he was like
he was like you got to make a fist
and you got a point like there's no
slapping
that's what i would do my instinct was
to go like that and and
another thing another thing i remember
him saying was
uh uh so he pulled me aside because he
thought i'd be like embarrassed but he
was like why are you screaming so much
you were making noise i was yeah he was
like why are you screaming and i was
like
because i'm i'm scared you know and he's
like why are you scared
because i'm in a fight yeah you know and
he's like well this is this is marvel
there's
there's no screaming like during the
fight like you could grunt but and i was
like
it's really tough for me not not to
scream i'm in the moment yeah
and uh but they worked with us for the
next
uh you know two weeks like every day and
they got it to a really good place and i
think that you know it turned out pretty
badass
all right i i haven't seen this
particular fight scene but let's take a
look now you're very proud of this
yeah um let's take a look at this uh
fight scene
uh that randall's in from one division
let's go
everybody in
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm sorry the action looks
good
yeah um can't they
edit out the shrieking well i toned down
the shrieking oh the choke oh that's
that's toned down
yeah i think it's pretty badass it's
very badass when i see something that i
think is truly badass
my reaction's a little weird is to laugh
very hard oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's why you never want to watch
like the matrix with me
because i'm just just howling right
right and people mistake it for
laughing at it when it's but yeah no not
at all yeah
yeah i mean i was so proud well you
should be proud
you